[Music]
hey everybody every damn day today we're
gonna be talking about the South Park
preview clip and why Kris is dressed as
John McClane electric scooters are
invading South Park the kids are going
to get more candy than they've ever got
before and the parents are losing their
mind let's watch the clip look I got
nothing left all right what did you give
me some of those hat shoes those are
already accounted for about folks who
called in let me let me have watching
McCall it's those are from me I gotta
protect my own house look you gotta give
me some more candy there's nothing left
here you gotta go somewhere else
I love electric scooters but I want
scooters I do think this is a little bit
of an exaggeration because you got it
you got a doctor you don't have to dock
the scooter but you have to put the
kickstand up you got to make sure that
it's off and if you put a scooter down
for too long even five minutes someone
else gets your scooter you can't be like
oh this is my scooter I'm gonna run to
the store and come out and it will be
there oh they're just out there yeah
we're out there at any moment I'm
totally taking it one time a girl went
into the store and I was like she came
out was like no that's my scooter and I
was like no it's now yeah and they it
already you you're the problem the first
time I've heard this already paid the
dollar initiation fee so I wasn't gonna
be like okay it's this random girl
scooter I was like Sulu
for the people that don't know these are
electric scooters or things that you
don't have to dock you can just leave
them anywhere and people pick them up
they're going across the whole nation
right now
Bloomington was just like don't bring
them to us because like a kid got hurt
some people are getting hurt with these
things
and you know every day yeah I've seen a
dog's head get stuck in one of those
like everything was fine I'm just saying
like those can be dangerous I get the
moral of yeah I mean booties are just a
database I got clipped so much red pegs
as a kid ride pegs hold on what are your
predictions for this tonight or tomorrow
night's episode are the kids can they
what's gonna happen I think they're
gonna get clipped in the ankles all
those kids are gonna get caught in
closes no I'm gonna eat candy cuz
they'll be in the hospital oh I think
that the kids need to relax
you don't need all that candy go savory
that's the move no one's really a fan of
you give out candy on Halloween we
didn't celebrate grilling burgers and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like riding the pumpkin Boathouse but
also the best how they deceive down to
him we had a house that gave out
king-size candy bars down the street and
that word travels very fast oh yeah yeah
sorry we don't grow up in whatever
houseboat you go to that house and that
was it
I said houseboat because I was trying to
think of something really fancy and I
really miss them mr. boat yeah I was in
Lebanon gated community you live in a
mansion no Hanna's rich right free pay I
don't steal free pants out of the trash
it wasn't in the trash it was on top of
the trash and it was meant to be given
away you can't steal free pants right
sometimes group costumes don't really
work out let's check out what South Park
has to say oh wow look honey it's
Ironman Captain America Thor and Bruce
Vilanch I'm not Bruce Vilanch Oh what
are you supposed to be all right you're
supposed to be that um incredible right
right the incredible Chaz Bono remember
honey Dancing with the Stars the fat
transsexual Oh cute
no not Chaz Bono you see my skin I'm
green the incredible Harvey Fierstein no
Harvey Fierstein is just gay and fat
honey he's not green the person I'm
dressed at is not fat and not gay the
incredibly fat and gay skinny straight
man daddy it stands to be Captain
America costume that's what's slowing
everybody off how are people supposed to
get that I'm the Hulk when Captain
America is on frickin FaceTime
trick-or-treat oh wow it's the Avengers
that's right oh and honey boo boo kids
come see the green honey boo boo costume
has anybody have you dressed up as
somebody and then they they didn't know
who was on Friday I wore a pink wig and
I was like supposed to be Natalie
Portman
from closer because I look a lot like
Natalie Portman and everyone thought I
was Joan Rivers
oh I went to a party this weekend and me
and my girlfriend were a pig in a
blanket and she wore a pig like cutout
like Anna knows and I just wore a
blanket and so everyone just thought I
was like cold for the party yeah the pig
would be wearing the blanket yeah well
we were just there when we hugged it
would it's cute
well is it a pig in a blanket or to the
people in a play you have three
iterations we had pig in a blanket we
had pig and a blanket and we had pig
against him like and that's when she was
mad at me the party on Saturday cuz you
know I also get invited to parties and I
was afraid to guess everyone's costume
because I couldn't tell who was in
street clothes and not well yeah I went
as Cleveland from yeah no one knew they
thought I was the bouncer still he kept
giving me ideas they didn't know oh
that's great what are you today oh
nothing my church is that dirty hey
spill coffee oh hell are you talking
about regular shirt nearly dressed as
John McClane from die hard and we know
that because you you've already worn
this outfit were made for the show I
know was here and my other shirt was
dirty
so you put on a Halloween costume tea
party or shirt a costume we had an
episode about Bruce Willis where he
dressed up as Bruce Willis characters I
think it was really the same coffee from
that epic
yeah it's great speaking of weird
costumes let's see what South Park has
to say
hey Ginny you guys dudette costumes
we're actually on our way over to Kyle's
because our costumes are so multifaceted
in queue we have to put them on together
whoo
what are you supposed to be butters I'm
a webicon you know a leprechaun that's
been bitten by a werewolf and jimmies
gangam scab what what what jingim Stan
yeah really cool guys
you'll be some stiff competition at the
costume contest for sure come on what do
you guys going is you'll just have to
wait and see
we're pecan right let's think of other
Halloween mashup costumes that'll be fun
take two things and then put them
together okay not really fun not a good
question and I like that clip I thought
it was great
I like South Park I love butters I
thought let me share this with my
friends and that we're just staring at
me okay how about about Captain Crunch
but in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
[Laughter]
Captain Crunch is Captain Barbossa will
be captain crunchy world alright our
next clip is yeah that's it where do we
go now I have more questions but I come
after our next clip which is from the
South Park episode hell on earth it
features the devil who is a prominent
figure in the South Park universe so
let's check out this clip from the year
[Music]
Halloween is a night for evil it is time
for me to take what is mine what do you
plan Lord Satan on Halloween we shall
open the gates of Hell rise up to the
earth and we will rent out the entire W
Hotel for an awesome party and invite a
bunch of celebrities how big a party we
talking have you seen those rich spoiled
teenage girls who have massive sweet 16
parties that big Halloween is about me
and I deserve a party this shall be my
super sweet 16 w hotel I mean that's
kind of my place I immediately thought
about you and he said W Hotel what's
your favorite memory of this well it
would have to be after the Rose when I
might I was like oh yeah just come to
the pool and I was like oh I'm not gonna
drink today and that always turns into
blacking out extremely hard have a
couple drinks yeah and then I had a
flight back here that night so I got on
the flight in my wet bathing suit can we
show the picture show it I mean that was
it started no sunscreen I was like yeah
it turned into a massive pile people
were asking their cigarettes in the pool
Oh children there Chris have you ever
encountered the devil I think one of his
cousins are so there's been some pretty
weird people to have and I say if you
ever encounter somebody you think might
be one of the devil's minions just walk
away just get out of there get the
devil's minions join you go low eyes
that doesn't mean make you a devil's
minions pretty good pretty good men you
did you guys get what I was doing when
Hannah Ryan said pull the picture I went
like this that means put the picture in
my hands like this
Hey okay so who's got a shout-out today
Jordan I think you dude you want to pull
that up for us all right so yesterday we
played truth yesterday we played truth
or dog shot-caller and OG n said quote
what is 2+2 and be truthful that's in my
voice and then man I can't say that on
YouTube and shock scare them I think
that's probably Chris's voice because
Chris just didn't want to answer any
questions like that and my mom commented
on the facebook video that they posted
of this why are you doing this to
yourself
and then as emoji with the sadness I
just really need attention and you never
gave thanks for watching every damn day
like comment and subscribe and check us
out on Twitter on extra damn day
[Music]